he's been diving in this stretch of the
Mediterranean off the coast of Italy for
nearly 20 years
and for the past two decades David
Rinaldi has witnessed how much of the
human footprint has invaded the sea at
the bottom a plastic Wasteland
today's dive is to retrieve a plastic
table that he estimates has been there
for at least three years not so easy to
bring up to the surface
it's not the first time this is one of
the many Marvels that we collected and
over the years the water has become
warmer today the water is 26 degrees
Celsius on the surface and below it it
was 22 degrees many changes
inhabitants of the sea have had to adapt
by the looks of it the Catch of the Day
was rather plentiful and delicious but
the combined effect of pollution plastic
and warmer seawater is having an impact
that we're just beginning to know about
most probably these fish contain micro
Plastics in their tissue tiny pieces
smaller than five millimeters
undetectable to the naked eye which are
often found in our food chain
there isn't a day that passes where
Angelo griller says he doesn't find
plastic coat in his neck
he picked up a truck tire and a sunbed
but it's mainly bottles plates forks
bags fishnets buckets all plastic
is very resilient and can float for
years around the global oceans carrying
with them fungus bacteria and algae
which are happy with warmer water like
these days the increase of temperature
of the sea temperature is very favorable
create very favorable conditions for the
increase of the number and the quality
of bacterials in the water so if we are
studying the bacterias we can also
predict that with the increase of global
temperature and the Sea temperature the
number of these bacteria is going to
increase to increase as well
but changes to our ecosystem become
visible 40 to 50 years later but it's
already too late by then the damage is
done and chances of reverting it nearly
impossible